this program is brought to you by Emory
University
fundamentally the the drugs that we use
today are are very similar to the drugs
that we've used since the 1980s 1983 was
the the drug the drug that
revolutionized transplantation
cyclosporine was introduced since then
that class of drugs another drug very
similar to it have been the cornerstone
the foundation of immunosuppression so
it's been since 1983 since we've had a
new drug that has formed the foundation
of transplant preventing transplant
rejection
the first drug that we started to work
with with ctla4 IG that was that fusion
protein that blocked the immune system
and that proved to be very effective in
experimental systems in mice short
courses of that treatment could lead to
very prolonged survival of mouse
transplants in mice of course what we
really wanted was a drug that was
effective in people and so we began to
explore that same drug at the Yerkes
primate center and in those experiments
we were very disappointed to find that
that drug ctla4 IG had had really
minimal effects in preventing transplant
rejection so that led to an effort to
really understand the biology a little
bit better and to see if we could come
up with alternatives so again working
with scientists at bristol-myers peter
linsley and and robert peach we started
to understand how effective that bla
drug was at blocking the immune system
did it bind tightly enough to block the
immune system and it turned out in
retrospect it didn't bind very tightly
to the target that it needed to and so
an effort was undertaken to see if we
could introduce mutations or changes in
that drug to change its binding
characteristics and it turned out one of
those called le a 29 y which
subsequently became Belet acept bound
much better to its targets and so it's
similar doses it would have 10 times the
effect in in vitro or test-tube studies
and it was that drug that we went back
and tested in the primate and there the
effects were much more market and so it
appeared that it could be an alternative
to the cyclosporine class of drugs so
Belet a Supt was a second generation
version of ctla-4 IG
the cells of the immune system that
cause rejection are called T cells and
they need to get two signals to become
activated and cause that immune response
they need to recognize things as foreign
that's the t cell receptor and then they
also get the second signals which we
call co-stimulatory signals if a t-cell
gets both of both of those it'll expand
divide and attack the the transplant if
you deprive the t-cell of those
co-stimulatory signals with a
co-stimulation blocker that's what Belet
a Supt is then it'll get the recognition
signal but not the second signal or
co-stimulatory signal and then they
won't become fully activated in fact
most of those t-cells will go on to die
and so that allows us to prevent the
immune response specifically to the
transplant
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University